seo this is kenny calling from portland
i had an idea here i have a playstation
5 that i got from my work
but i would like to offer that to one of
your struggling single moms
so if you have any ladies out there that
are
trying to make your kid happy on the
holiday i have a playstation 5 that i'll
be willing to
donate game game gang gang man
thank you kenny that's man that's where
it's at we would love that
it's that time of year man it's that
time of year to to extend a little if
you can
you know the other day i was i was
eating breakfast here and i
ended up paying for the breakfast there
was a couple sitting outside
and when i walked in the guy said i said
hey and him and his girlfriend were just
visiting in town and so before i left i
just bought my meal bought their meal
and i'm just saying that because about
two weeks later
i'm across the street eating breakfast
at a different place
and we get up to pay and leave and they
said oh somebody bought your meal
i said dang didn't know who i don't know
who it was
you know some damn scrooge mcduck got
warm-hearted you know he grilled his own
a
orders with the lord he got heated in
the heart and somebody bought me that
damn meal
that's caramel roulette and that karma
will really this
this the time of year when karma is out
there karma got on the zoot suit
karma's listening to 21 savages karma
got his nose hairs clipped out he's out
there
this when karma is paying attention so
it's a great time to extend that olive
leaf to somebody
how can i help what can i do and when i
get up in the morning this week what's
been making me feel good
is just saying what can i do what can i
do for somebody that's not me
so anyway would a small little world
have that worked out but thank you kenny
we'll find somewhere we'll find someone
who can use it i think
so hit the hotline if you have some
suggestions and we did we had some calls
that came
in man uh here was the first one that
came in hey
this is mike from philadelphia
pennsylvania i just wanted to maybe
nominate my
my sister she works really hard she has
two kids one's eight
one's ten they're real big in the video
game so i thought that would be perfect
for them
they're great kids and she's an awesome
mom so thank you mike i didn't mean to
cut you off there man but um
yeah we're gonna we'll connect you with
kenny and um you know that's candyman
that's kenny helping out there those
things are hot commodity bro damn
dude somebody be dying of cancer you
offering some plasma they say no but you
hit them with that
and they want it bruh let's hit some
other people up hey theo
it's west from minneapolis man i have i
got an excellent single mom that uh
she's uh working to get her kid back she
has him about half the year right now
and she's gonna have him over christmas
she has a really great kid who is a big
gamer and
she manages a gas station so she's out
there grinding every day but
amen brother i think we can help out
with that um let me give you a buzz
right now
hello what's up wes bro how you living
man
good who's this this is theo man theovon
the comedian
oh get out of town man what's up
brothers
not much brother's looking for the lord
you know me boy
amen amen yeah i appreciate your call
man it's really nice of you to call just
that you left on the uh hotline
we'd already found somebody already had
called before they got the ps5 but
there's a company that helps us out
sometimes this company called magic mind
and they wanted to offer uh
a ps4 or i think it's a ps4
and a television maybe i don't know if
the kiddo would you know if that would
be something that they would like
man that would be amazing dude you have
no idea how awesome you just made my day
dude you made me feel good man i
appreciate it man have a good day dude
and we'll circle up with you bro and
thanks for thinking of somebody else man
awesome peace all right gang i feel my
name is tim carter
i figure let's call in right now and see
what we can do
hello hey what's up man this is theo von
brah uh
i'm calling just about you called a
couple um about the podcast about the
we're talking about the playstation
yes sir my gosh i wow how are you
thank you so much for calling oh yeah
man no worries man thank you for calling
bro
so we gave away the playstation somebody
else had called before you but we wanted
to we want to do something nice
maybe we could just at least set you
guys up with like a gift card or
something maybe to best buy or to some
other place
wow tio i just i just don't know what to
say man i just
i wasn't expecting this at all and i
think that's a great idea and that will
be just such a great christmas this is
her first christmas in portland and
that'll oh
that'll just be so awesome so awesome
thank you
man thank you bro i don't know these
people but it's just you know it's your
own kindness and your own thinking about
somebody else and
it's funny how one thing like that kind
of spurns the other ones you know
all right gang tim bro be good man okay
thank you
all right cheers brother hi theo
this is susie again um i'm a single mom
i have been looking for this ps5
everywhere and i'm trying to get it for
my daughter for christmas
she's been doing really good in school
here in michigan we've been
shut down because of the rhona mm-hmm i
feel you baby
that dirty rona bruh that's that long
aids baby let me call you
see what we can do hello hey what's up
who's this
hey it's susie what up
susie
i want to thank you first of all just
for thinking to somebody else and just
you know calling and leaving your
voicemail
i thought it was really sweet of you the
problem is we already gave away the ps5
but i wanted to try and think of
something else that we could do
that you think would be nice oh my god i
don't even know what to say
how about this i know it's kind of
impersonal but what if we just gave you
like a 500
gift card and you could do something
nice for you guys something that you
wanted to do
i know not a ps5 but um
no i appreciate it so much we've
we've been struggling i mean i try to
you know
you know my attitude is always positive
but just to hear from you
is just wow speechless
well that's sweet of you thanks thank
you for making my day and thanks for the
nice words
thank you thank you so much merry
christmas to you your family
like i love your podcast i can't wait to
hear the next one oh my god i don't even
know
wow thank you for the phone call you're
welcome sushi
thank you you bet we love you bye-bye
hey tio uh my name's caroline i'm from
gastonia north carolina right outside of
charlotte
my nephew was diagnosed with cancer um
like a year and a half ago but i was
just listening to
your podcast and i heard about the um
the guy
that has the playstation he was wanted
to donate
and um my sister she has two kids
and her oldest son adam he just passed
away in
october from cancer he was 16 and then
she has
a younger son andrew and um
he will be 15. he just lost his brother
and
i know she was trying to find like the
new xbox or the new playstation to give
to him for christmas that would kind of
be special
but well thank you so much for this
uh see if i can get a hold of you hey
caroline hello hey what's up this is
theo i'll call you called uh into the
podcast the other day from the podcast
oh my god yes how are you
[ __ ] how are you i'm laying on my floor
right now
freaking out oh damn well look just
you know what i'm saying keep your
clothes on shorty i don't want to get
accused of nothing you know
oh my god i was literally just talking
about you
i'm like speechless right now my face is
like pulsating
you might be on drugs i think damn i'm
not
i feel like i am but i'm not okay well
look it sound like
if your damn faces pull satan you might
want to g up a little bit you might want
to
you know you might want to use a skin
softener or something
no i just wanted to say your message was
so sweet i thought it was very nice you
to call and uh
i think playstations are just all sold
out so we're committed to help find like
a um
xbox do you think the kids would want
that or do you think we should just wait
and
whenever playstations come back he would
prefer an xbox if he got an xbox he
would
poop in his pants well damn y'all's
whole family need to tighten up it
sounds like but uh
we're going through stuff all right
y'all be good all right stay off them
percocets girl you know it
okay i will okay deal deal deal and i
will too
okay okay good okay deal
bye oh man that's great
that's sweet